[Applaudissements]
si dans ce spectacle il y en a partout
mais alors on y va
je vous donne des phrases ont glissé de
vous pas oui et demain en cas d'orage
éloigné jacques dutronc et écoute c'est
possible que ça s'est passé c'est moi
c'est moi oui c'est possible c'est vous
tout craché l'équipe autour de la table
pour une chose chez vous aussi un mot
demandez-vous ce alex goude ou pas fait
gaffe à vos cheveux demain celle à
saint-ignace ça c'est précieux marais il
paraît que ce sont des gens très polis
les albères parce qu'on dit toujours
talent bonjour d'albert annoncé c'est
pas de vous et laurent romejko regarder
ça ce sont des gens très polis oui à
bercy on dit toujours talent bonjour
d'albert
[Applaudissements]
eddie cascio dit attention va se
réveiller la tête dans le cumulus oui ça
c'est mauvais souhaiter une bonne fête à
ingrid mais elle si vous a énervé en
classe et will et ingrid sont souvent
des bêtes ont cours à web est en cours
c'est moi c'est la lan roumain vieux ou
lan roumanoff
non c'est pas moi je parle jamais c'est
notre petit préféré fait les oreilles de
zahedan
oui c'est le bar est un âne romain la
drôme un vieux oulad roumanoff gerra
bien un petit pas pour l'homme un grand
pas pour l'humidité
ça c'est moi aussi je me faisais payer
c'est tous les jours faut bien trouver
les moyens de t'amuser donc je me
creuser la tête 10 rebonds comment je
peux dire qu'il fait pas beau demain et
voilà je suis solidaire je suis
solidaire simon groupe à part cela
aujourd'hui nous fêtons les henry donc
sortait lui une bonne blague pour qu ils
ont ri c'est lui enfin surtout moi cela
c'est la station de souabe non je suis
pas sûr malheureusement c'est vous
[Applaudissements]